[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de la
entrevista nos acompañe en el estudio en
el señor Juan Coín Vélez ministro
francés delgado para el comercio
exterior y el atractivo económico que
viene a hablarnos no solamente de su
visita a Colombia y otros países de la
región sino también a tratar temas de
suma importancia para la concesión de
Francia en la actualidad y también al
futuro yo está
por preguntarle cuáles son los objetivos
de su visita no solo a Colombia sino
también a Ecuador y República Dominicana
silencia el corazón se arregla reforzar
los vínculos económicos entre Francia y
la región en particular con los tres
países que mencionan y empezamos aquí
casino Sanofi pero muchas otras quieren
invertir estoy como una delegación de 25
empresas pymes y grandes grupos que
quiere invertir aquí en el sector de
energía renovable sector de la vida
sostenible de la construcción de los
transportes de las nuevas tecnologías
[Música]
y de un crecimiento débil en 2022 y
también de muchas desigualdades en la
región en este contexto que retos pero
también que oportunidades de Francia
estás sola también queremos aprovechar
las oportunidades que se ofrecen aquí en
Colombia debido a las reformas en pro de
los negocios que se han llevado a cabo y
que permiten que haya un ambiente más
favorable para el desarrollo de las
empresas
para seguir hablando un poco cerca de la
pandemia de covid-19 que está haciendo
Francia en este momento frente a la
pandemia existen áreas de cooperación en
el ámbito de la salud entre Francia y
los países de América Latina
[Música]
partir ciertas maneras de hacer las
cosas
que se puede mejorar mucho en la región
[Música]
fue ministro de Cultura hasta el 2020 el
año de la pandemia
ha aprendido y qué consejos puede dar
para proteger a un sector que es muy
importante pero también muy vulnerable a
la crisis sanitaria
mejor las oportunidades que ofrece el
entorno digital es claro que durante la
pandemia tuvimos más acceso a la cultura
a través de Internet a través del
entorno digital y las ambiciones que
tenemos en Francia y las que tienen aquí
el presidente colombiano en materia de
economía naranja en materia de
industrias culturales y creativas son
similares
Estados Unidos y Australia a causa del
pacto de Defensa ocurre y la crisis de
los submarinos con todo ese panorama que
esperan en 2022 para Francia
anuncio colombiana última cop26 en
materia de cambio climático es
absolutamente innovador y ambicioso y
queremos acompañar a Colombia en este
aspecto
te
guardo las preguntas acerca de la
política interior para política interior
francesa
Francia jugará un papel importante en
particular a través de la Presidencia de
la Unión Europea
o cuando el clima se calienta debemos
mantenernos alerta y utilizar la
política comercial para luchar contra el
calentamiento global a favor de la
biodiversidad y contra deforestación
dijo que está hecho si es
el diálogo franco y directo que tenemos
con los países de Mercosur
tenemos relaciones muy fuertes con los
pueblos de esa región del mundo con los
pueblos de Mercosur con el pueblo
europeo
porque tenemos
muchos valores en común y lo queremos
seguir desarrollando el futuro
importante a través de presupuestos de
la materia de salud en materia de
reconversión de una cierta cantidad de
gente
para que la agricultura sea sostenible
energías renovables
[Música]
información una información que permite
desencriptar la actualidad que permite
entender las cosas tomar un poco de
distancia tener perspectiva y esa es tal
vez la mirada específica que tiene
Francia sobre la actualidad y sobre ese
trabajo de información que los
periodistas y todo el equipo de France
24 hacen de manera absolutamente
extraordinaria así que es un buen
aniversario a pocos meses de los 4 años
disfraces de cuatro aquí y además es el
aniversario de los 15 años de France 24
en el mundo entero es un gran orgullo
para nosotros como antiguo ministro de
Cultura puede tener una perspectiva muy
particular sobre francés de 4 y de
manera más amplia sobre el público
francés y estoy muy orgulloso porque
estoy a muchas gracias gracias a usted
era el señor
Ministro delegado francés para el
comercio exterior y el atractivo
económico que no sabes cómo es
información en France 24 y france24.com
y siguen conectados a nuestra
programación